if you are a veteran of state of decay
obsessed with min maxing your bases or a
new player interested in living that
best zombie life state of decay
juggernaut Edition wants to find
something for you
there are new places to explore new
weapons to swing and new ways for
beginners to learn the game here are 7
ways state of decay 2 is getting better
with the juggernaut Edition number 1 a
new map juggernaut takes place in
Providence Ridge a Pacific Northwest
logging town in the process of being
gentrified
there are gentrified zombies the map
fields medium sized for state of decay
game I drove all the way around it in
one session but offers a bit more
variety when it comes to terrain and
atmosphere number 2 better graphics with
less jank when you fire up the game
you'll notice it looks better that's
because there's been a visual overhaul
in both the environment and menus the UI
has been tweaked to help you find
missions more easily and convey timely
information so you know you don't die
well in Providence Ridge you'll notice
better weather such as fog and thicker
forests if you wander off into those
forests you may find some Easter eggs
there have also been tweaks to how
Knight works making it easier for you to
see in the dark undead laps has also put
a lot of work into reducing the jank
although personally I've always found it
a bit endearing number 3 new weapons in
this addition you'll find a new class of
two-handed melee weapons that are good
for crowd control they require a bit of
practice and better timing but man as it
fun when you connect number 4 a better
introduction when you start the game
there's a beginner base with quests that
teach players about state of decay twos
of many many systems it's a game that
hasn't necessarily been easy to learn in
the past and requires new players to
manage multiple survivors upgrade and
maintain bases manage resources battle
infections craft and set up outposts all
while surviving moments a moment for
veterans though you can drive right on
past that base and get started number 5
much larger bases developers refer to
one or two of the new bases as a no
spaces because you can become
all-powerful these bases are large
enough to accommodate far more upgrades
and you can min/max without having to
make tough trade-offs these bases do
make a lot of noise and attract a lot of
attention but to compensate one fire
station in particular comes with a bell
across the street that you can ring to
lure hordes away assuming you can make
the shot
number six cost if you're a first-time
buyer the game runs $29.99 if you
already own state of decay - you're all
set the update is free juggernaut adds
all previous DLC to your copy so
everyone with the game is on the same
page if you already bought DLC like
Heartland then you'll get some special
in-game rewards like a prestige bonus
and special outfits the game is also
included with Microsoft game past which
devs credited for giving them the space
to make this remaster number 7 new
platform juggernaut edition brings state
of decay to steam so you don't have to
try and remember where the hell
Microsoft Store went on your PC anymore
the game will of course be out for
current gen Xbox consoles and offer
cross play everywhere it's available
state of decay - juggernaut Edition will
be out March 13 so are you a stay of
decay fan like I am if you've never
played it's pretty much the Sims meets
the zombie apocalypse speaking of if you
love zombie games head on over to
GameSpot's youtube page to see the
history of nazi zombies I'm Aaron
Sampson
and thanks for watching
[Music]